stay 24 the partial government shutdown
over funding for border wall the
president hunkering down in DC over the
weekend willing to work on a compromise
one but about 30 Democrats left him
hanging choosing instead to take off for
a winter retreat in Puerto Rico the
president blasting Democrats earlier
today I've been here all weekend a lot
of the Democrats were in Puerto Rico
celebrating something I don't know maybe
they're celebrating the shutdown we have
a very big crisis that humanitarian
crisis on the border we have a priority
it's the safety of our nation the
southern border has been horrible for
decades and it's now because of the
success of our country it's now at a
level that we cannot put up with the
Democrats have to do something we need
their votes otherwise we can solve it
let's see if they can lead I don't know
that they can lead but we're going to
soon find out meanwhile Republican
Senator Lindsey Graham suggesting the
president opened the government for a
short period of time in order to
negotiate a solution here's the
president's response to that well that
was a suggestion that Lindsey made but I
did I did reject it yes I'm not
interested I want to get it solved I
don't want to just delay it I want to
get it job all right let's go back to
the Puerto Rico trip all right so I
don't know if we have the picture but
you know senator Menendez from New
Jersey
shirtless there he is out by the beach
talking the talk you know all lotioned
up you know got the daiquiris food we
have that lower third up he's down there
with lobbyists from Big Tobacco Silicon
Valley the unions and he's fresh off an
ethics scandal here I think the
reporters maybe should look into a story
about that as opposed to this this
Russia collusion situation there's meat
on those bones I'm not talking about -
well I'm assume well having just come
off the ethical problem I would assume
that the trip that they tried to dot all
their eyes and cross our T's so that
there wasn't an ethical problem there is
a public perception problem sure right
so you go down there though if I were
the Democrats I might turn around and
say really well we're in Puerto Rico you
know the place where you said you were
going to take funds from their hurricane
relief to pay for your wall yeah that's
why we're here
[Music]
something that the president said today
in the last week if the Democrats were
just willing to take all the little a la
carte menus that he mentions in these
interviews or appearances that he does
they actually there's a making for a
really good comprehensive immigration
reform bill last week he said hey you
know those h-1b visas the best and the
brightest the smartest like I'll tell
you what don't go to don't go anywhere
else come here and we'll give you a
permanent citizenship that wasn't on the
table before today when he's talking to
the farmers he said I know you guys need
workers they all start cheering he says
boy I'm glad I brought it up I will make
sure you have the workers last week he
said he would do daca I'm like okay so
for five billion dollars for border
security which Democrats have already
said that they're for why not take him
up on all of these things that he's
willing to do because they're working on
their tans yes that is why Greg yeah
they're gonna pay the price for
something like this if the Republicans
had done this during a shutdown and gone
tanning in Puerto Rico or anywhere they
would have been hit hard no matter what
vacations are bad for politicians
because there's always something going
on that's serious and they have enough
vacation yes and and it's just rarely
good optics to see a politician without
his clothes on it's your crack
bureaucrats should be fully clothed at
all times that's just for me hey could I
respond I was listening to Howard Stern
today and he expressed an argument that
I've heard before about why walls don't
work right he said it's because of
tunnels and I've been thinking about
this and I go you could argue that
tunnels are proof that walls work
because it forces the criminal to engage
in riskier more involve time-consuming
endeavors for example even out of a wall
then you don't have to dig a tunnel for
example you could use the same argument
it like why would I buy a lock for my
bike if somebody has bolt cutters
well you reduce the risk of your bike
getting stolen the same way the walls
reduce the risk of crossover so
deterrence always and this goes back to
the whole idea of going to legal ports
of entry drugs all deterrence do is they
funnel efforts of the criminals into
more difficult labor-intensive arenas
that is a success so walls are no
tunnels or with tunnels are still
competent well if Howard's listening
absolutely that was my gentle
Botts yes what do you think about this
my optics and and Greg's amazing
analysis of the tunnel is about
politicians having their clothes on but
especially Bob Menendez who's had some
problems with the islands in the past
maybe he should be a little more careful
Washington DC is very quiet right now
right and Democrats who claim to be
fighting for middle class government
workers who skipped their first paycheck
it's one thing to skip one paycheck if
you skip another one that's the entire
month right that creates even more
problems than you had the first time you
skipped a paycheck for them to be down
on the beach lotioning up young women as
we saw in that photo while they're
partying with lobbyists who make
millions and millions of dollars in
Washington DC as a result of these
contracts it looks pretty bad and
hypocritical on top of all of these
other issues they're not coming to the
table on when it comes to rejecting
Lindsey Graham's solution he says open
it up for a couple of weeks the
president already put that on the table
with Nancy Pelosi in the Oval Office and
said if I open up the government in 30
days will you give me some funding for
this barrier wall and she said no right
so Democrats have already said doesn't
matter if you open up the government and
so it's up to them now and we're talking
about five billion dollars not even
talking about the 26 billion as Dana
said they put so much on the table at
the White House in terms of compromise
not even for the entire section of the
wall that they're looking for this is a
tiny portion of what he's actually
asking for well I mean I say two quick
responses one is the President had a
deal on the table that he rejected that
would have given the dreamers and some
other four people is protect the status
part of a deal right in exchange for the
wall way back and guess what Steve
Miller and the president said no we want
to cut legal immigration by half the
second thing to say is we know what
regard to the Republican effort ongoing
now to try to get some kind of
negotiation on the hill what you've
heard from people like Chris Coons who
was on Fox News Sunday yesterday is
we're willing to negotiate but we need
somebody who's reliable and the
president shifts in terms of what he
wants and what he doesn't want on a
regular basis so that even his top aides
can't be confident as to what will make
a deal and finally you know what this I
think there's a
kradic retreat I think there's a show of
Hamilton lin-manuel Miranda's show was
down there and a lot of the politicians
of God
Republicans have retreats and sunny
places and ended all the shutdown I
don't know what they're doing this
January I don't know where it is but
they're brave me they're scheduled to
have a retreat on the beach so yeah the
shirts are on I don't look so that's the
issue no I think this again is an effort
you say you know we can caricature we
can mock but you know what guys let's be
serious for me people really are let's
not be serious shirtless in Puerto Rico